bonjour à tous vous allez poursuivre
dans un instant la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi macron les sénateurs sont
en train d'examiner la partie concernant
les professions réglementées
samedi après midi ils ont voté l'article
13 bis un article qui donne compétence
au seul ministre de la justice pour
établir la carte d'implantation des
zones où les nouveaux offices notariaux
pourront justement s'implanter librement
alors cet après midi ils continuent
d'examiner cette partie concernant les
professions réglementées et en
particulier les notaires un amendement
déposé par le gouvernement propose de
revenir à la version adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale alors que la
commission spéciale du sénat avait
restreint la portée des mesures
libéralisant l'accès à la profession de
notaire
voilà tout de suite donc on écoute
l'examen de l'article 14 et on en
reparle à 19h dans le journal présenté
par delphine girard l'ordre du jour
appelle la suite de la discussion du
projet de loi considéré comme adopté par
l'assemblée nationale en application de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la constitution
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée pour la croissance
l'activité et l'égalité des chances
économiques dans la discussion des
articles nous sommes parvenus à
l'article 14 à l'article 14
l'amendement 773 rectifié n'est pas
soutenue je passe donc en 1619 présenté
par le gouvernement monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole
oui bonjour monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
présidents
c'est un amendement mais on fera on sera
de temps en temps à mener mais celle ci
n'atteint karoutchi à aller à aller dans
cette voie mais j'ai essayé d'expliquer
expliquer pourquoi le gouvernement a
pris acte donc du vote de l'article 13
bis dans la version issue de la
commission spéciale et de l'insertion
l'état de l'article 15 tel que voté par
l'assemblée qui poserait ainsi désormais
de réelles difficultés de cohérence et
en particulier noté que vous avez
maintenu le principe de l'extension de
la compétence des huissiers à la cour
d'appel
mais vous avez simplement décalé
l'entrée en vigueur au 1er janvier 2017
alors je suis d'accord avec cette
nouvelle date d'entrée en vigueur mais
spécifiquement pour les huissiers car il
faut pour cette profession prendre en
compte l'extension de leurs compétences
au niveau départemental depuis le le 1er
janvier 2015 et le nécessaire temps
d'adaptation en revanche comme pour les
notaires nous ne partageons pas
l'aménagement que vous avez fait pour
les départs en retraite à 70 ans et la
mesure transitoire ne fixe pas de limite
pour le départ effectif en retraite
je vous demande donc de rétablir cette
limite présente simplement merci
monsieur le ministre avait de la
commission tu le rapporteur ce président
de ce mini smessaert collègues
votre amendement monsieur le ministre
procède d'un rétablissement sec
les dispositions de l'assemblée
nationale il est vous vous doutez bien
que ça n'est pas de nature enchanté la
commission se faisant effectivement vous
v
vous proposer de revenir sur les
modifications qui ont été apportées par
notre commission spéciale qui 1 à
clarifier la rédaction de l'article iv
en évoquant l'existence de zones
intermédiaires qui n'étaient pas traités
par l'article 13 bis dont vous avez
d'ailleurs convenu expression lord et on
revient sur ce point gris et vous la
commission a maintenu pour 50
les habilitations de claire prononcer
avant le 1er janvier 2015 en effet
compte tenu de la situation de très
grande incertitude économique dans
laquelle les notaires vont être placés
les peu vraisemblable qu'ils embauchent
des notaires salariés en masse pour
remplacer les clercs habilité en outre
le délai d'un an est bien insuffisant
ces derniers qui voient leur leur statut
complètement bouleversée pour se
préparer à devenir notaire salariés
n'oublions pas cette suppression va
nuire assez clair habilité qui ne
pourront devenir notaire parce qu'elle
aboutira à réduire leur rémunération ou
parce qu'elle peut nuire à leur
licenciement pour favoriser l'embauché
de notaire salariés un délai de 5 ans
est donc nécessaire pour qu'au moins
socialement cela permette cette
reconversion à marche forcée de
s'accomplir sans heurt enfin notre
commission avait supprimé la limite de
l'exercice au delà de six mois par un
auteur âgé de plus de 70 ans dans la
tempe que son successeur prête serment
setting risque de jouer contre nos
concitoyens en laissant vacant et nos
fils alors que son titulaire est
d'accord pour continuer à exercer sa
charge le temps que l'ensemble des
formalités de la nomination de son
successeur soit faite alors pense pas
qu'on puisse crainte que le ministre de
la justice maintiennent à son poste
envers et contre tout un ministre plus
âgés un notaire plus âgés
ça c'est c'est peut-être une crainte qui
serait plus partagés en retardant par
des manoeuvres dilatoires la prestation
de serment de son successeur alors je
pense que ce dispositif d'ailleurs qui
s'applique en alsace moselle n'a donné
lieu à aucun contournement n'ai aucun
excès petites erreurs que j'ai commises
en confondant le notaire ministre ariel
peut-être amené à s'expliquer sur
quelquefois lâche et la limite d'âge qui
ne s'appliquerait pas à ces derniers la
commission spéciale et donc désireuses
de connaître votre avis sur ces trois
points encore que vous les allées et
expliquer brièvement tout à l'heure et
donc en l'état de nos discussions
c'était évidemment un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur il ya des
explications de vote
je n'en vois pas je mets donc aux voix
la bande mobile 619 avec un avis
défavorable de la commission qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adoptée et nous passons au 221
rectifié celle-ci routiers qu'ils
prêtent très bien ce sera au comptant du
mercy le président et le suivi de chaque
relais le présent amendement a pour
objet supprimer la limite d'âge qui a
été instauré pour les gars si c'est des
fantômes de l'auteur alors que celui-ci
travail françois rebsamen encourageant
pas des seniors qui est avéré que la
france le taux d'emploi des seniors
parmi les plus bas du continent du fait
politique malthusienne division du
travail ne comprend pas de telles
positions
faudra-t-il ainsi qu'un doté à qui a
travaillé tout service interac de 10 ans
alors même qu'ils ne souhaitent pas il
en va différemment lorsqu'ils est avéré
que la personne n'est plus en mesure de
travailler concrètes correctement mais
cette assemblée générale qui interdit
d'exercice des missions des notaires à
présent de 10 à sa part en des formes de
discriminations liées à l'âge
ce qui est inacceptable
je m'approche haut niveau il faut
rappeler que l'union européenne s'est
fixé pour objectif à long terme
d'encourager les villes se maquille ce
d'âge l avantage pour tirer parti du
potentiel des personnes à la fin de la
cinquantaine ou plus âgés et enfin de
préserver les solidarité
intergénérations la condition avoir opn
du principe de non-discrimination
directive 2001/18 correspond aux
objectifs poursuivis par l'europe dans
le cadre d'une stratégie européenne pour
l'emploi aussi à la promotion des
ministres à qui ces directives adour à
cette année la foire est un outil
juridique pour enrayer la dissimulation
la boj dans son ultime les travailleurs
âgés mais elle prend également en
considération le sac cas particulier et
et l'âge dans le cas des politiques
entre l'emploi elle impose donc aux
états m abbas de l'exitation nationale
ci puisse interdire la discrimination
directe et indirecte ainsi que le
harcèlement et les rétorsions au
modelage la liberté la règle la
restriction l'exception le comprend donc
la suppression de la limite d'âge pour
toutes les professions réglementées
âgées titeuf c'est une série télé l'avis
de la commission de ce rapporteur
présidente féminisme chers collègues le
notaire n'est pas un professionnel le
libéral comme un autre il est nommé par
l'autorité ministérielle et s'il
n'occupe à un emploi public il est
dépositaire de prérogatives de puissance
publique
ce faisant il est légitime ou en tout
cas légalement possible d'encadrer
l'exercice de sa profession fixer une
limite d'âge à l'exercice de ses
fonctions est tout à fait conforme au
droit de l'état d'organiser le
fonctionnement des offices publics
ministériels
bien sûr cela contribuera la circulation
des offices et c'est d'autant plus
facile à la commission de soutenir cette
thèse que lors des auditions je n'ai pas
entendu d'opposition des notaires sur ce
point merci c'est l'avis du gouvernement
j'aurai le même avis défavorable mais
c'est le sénateur parce que d'abord on
voit que c'est une profession qui doit
se rajeunir il ya juste 6% d'être
installés qui ont qui ont moins de qui
ont moins on fait ce qu'on peut déjà
avec ce qu'on a
donc en l'espèce on s'occupe de ces
professions réglementées à 6% moi
de 35 ans ensuite cette limite de 70 en
existe dans le régime d'alsace-moselle
qu'on a évoqué donc ce n'est pas non
plus une aberration et c'est une bonne
référence
enfin c'est en effet la réforme qui
avait été proposé par le texte sorti de
l'assemblée nationale mais comme je suis
cohérent et que on va au bout nos
arguments c'est pour ça aussi que je
pète pour s'en donner les moyens et que
je trouve dommage de ne pas s'être
laissé cette limite de six mois qui
permet de s'organiser de faire la
succession et et là-dessus permettre
même au delà de 70 ans à un notaire de
conserver son office sans limite dans le
temps
c'est créer les conditions pour qu'une
organisation se fasse on aura beaucoup
de sans mauvais jeu de mots de clause de
grand-père qui s'organiseront néanmoins
pour toutes les raisons que je viens
d'évoquer
je jeu j'aurai un avis défavorable sur
votre votre amendement le rapporteur sur
le dernier point évoqué par monsieur le
ministre ce n'est pas à la volonté
strict du notaire c'est le garde des
sceaux et qu'ils aient un terme et c'est
dans le cadre d'une session qui est en
train de s'effectuer
c'est uniquement pour donner de la
souplesse ça n'affecte pas du tout la
limite d'âge que voulait imposer
et puis ça va se poser dans des calmes
et exceptionnel merci explications de
vote je ne vois pas je vais donc voilà
moment 221 rectifier avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour et des contre
1,10 s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée
nous passons aux 470 c2c ça vous avez la
parole chez le président monsieur le
ministre
madame la rapporteure monsieur
rapporteur monsieur le président la
commission
chers amis chers collègues - une étude
de le céder à réaliser en 2013 établi
qu'une véritable égalité professionnelle
hommes/femmes contribuerait à accroître
de 10 % l'économie de notre pays d'ici
2030 c'est bientôt
or les chiffres de la dgcis sur la
profession de notaire sont sans
équivoque 0 1% de femmes notaire ou
moins de 30 ans 71% des notaires sont
des hommes en août 85% des associés sont
des hommes gagnant plus de 16000 euros
quand par mois quand 84 % des salariés
sont des femmes rémunérées aux alentours
de 4000 euros par mois il convient donc
de créer des conditions de
titularisation égalitaire pour les
femmes dans les offices existants et
d'inscrire le principe de parité dans
l'article 14
c'est le sens de cet amendement la
rédaction de l'article 4 de la loi du 25
ventôse an noz et les conditions invoqué
pour la titularisation aux qualités de
nos terres sont discriminantes pour les
femmes notamment les plus jeunes
en août la forme la formulation actuelle
de l'article 14 contrevient à
l'obligation de résultats en termes
d'égalité professionnelle salariée à
l'est de mixité entre les sexes figurant
dans la loi relative à l'égalité réelle
entre les femmes et les hommes
enfin les contraires à l'article 6 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen selon laquelle tous les citoyens
sont également admissibles à toutes
dignités places et emplois publics selon
leur capacité et sans autre distinction
que celle de leurs vertus et de leurs
talents et avis de la commission
oui le président cet amendement vise à
instaurer une liberté d'installation
total des notaires ce faisant il est en
contradiction totale avec le projet de
loi avec les travaux de la commission
spéciale il peut je ne peux que fait
naître un avis défavorable d'ailleurs je
note que s'il est très libéral pour
l'installation
il est très régulier pour l'évolution
des offices existants donc en toute
hypothèse la région du premier point que
vous avez développé ça ne peut être
qu'un avis défavorable mais ma vie donc
défavorable
explications de vote je ne vois pas je
mets donc on vous à l'amendement 470
avec deux avis défavorables pied pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté nous passons à 10 12
amendements pardon en discussion commune
le 734 monsieur xavier oui monsieur
présent monsieur ministre madame
monsieur monsieur rapporterait président
chers collègues
effectivement il vous est proposé de
remplacer la mine et a6 qui stipule
qu'un nouveau décret en conseil d'état
fixera les conditions requises pour être
nommée en qualité de notaire puisque
aujourd'hui il existe des conditions
d'aptitude qui sont déjà définis à
l'article 3 du décret sont très 609 du 5
juillet 1973 relatif à la formation
professionnelle dans le notariat et aux
conditions d'accès aux notaires et bien
sûr avec la situation particulière
d'alsace-moselle aux articles sont dix
donc c'est n'y a pas nécessité d'avoir
un nouveau décret en conseil d'état
tim sloan y est le 120 rectifié n'est
pas soutenu le 228 rectifier mais ce
routier identique au précédent non
défendu
l'insurgé sa collègue comme cela a été
souligné aujourd'hui c'était sept années
d'études après un bac sont nécessaires
produire nos terres cette formation
longue permet de garantir accueil
service ranini paris l'auteur nous
propose aux hommes par cet amendement
qui est de 128 et 215 je laisse le temps
de bangor critères de diplôme soit à
l'affût petits carreaux fille
territoriales ce soit à le cumul à ce
critère monsieur qui est le 285 rétifié
qu'un pièce madame des rom est dit il
est défendu
il est défendu le 376 13 par nous
rectifier n'est pas défendu le 417 non
plus le 568 rectifié bis ne l'est pas le
649 rectifié dit ce monsieur mais des
vielles ou madame boulet oui monsieur le
président chers collègues il est déjà
défendu puisque c'est le même amendement
que les collègues ont défendu
précédemment il s'agit de remplacer les
mots d'expérience par les mots de
diplômes tout ça va de soi merci merci
madame boulet le 673 rectifié by side
entier que n'est pas défendu et le 1064
madame continuant oui monsieur le
président monsieur ministre mais chaque
col est bien cet amendement est le même
que ceux précédemment proposée par mes
collègues il nous semble indispensable
que l'accès de cette profession du droit
soient contrôlés par des exigences de
connaissances et de savoirs sanctionnées
par des diplômes reconnus soit merci le
215 rectifier il a été défendu et le 722
rectifié monsieur daumier
oui président ce ministre il vous est
proposé effectivement à travers cet
amendement de supprimer la notion de
justifier les conditions d'assurance
puisque la joute se disposition semble
tout à fait inutile dans la mesure où
l'un d'eux verts ont déjà à ce jour
l'obligation d'être assuré au regard du
décret 55 604 du 20 mai 1955 relatifs
aux officiers publics et hoministes
derrière la certains auxiliaires de
justice que ça soit à titre individuel
ou à titre collectif
cette assurance est déjà sous ce qui est
obligatoirement et monsieur le
rapporteur
tel est l'avis de la commission sur ces
différents amendements oui la vie sera
évidemment le même sur l'ensemble de ces
amendements dont je vais solliciter le
retrait pour la raison pour la raison
première c'est que nous avons déjà
évoqué ce point la semaine dernière à
propos de l'article 13 bis et que nous
avons écarté ce qui est sollicité
aujourd'hui
d'autre part la condition de diplôme
d'ailleurs des amendements avaient été
retirées par certains de nos collègues
les conditions de diplôme et les d'ores
et déjà incluse dans la notion
d'altitude donc il n'ya pas lieu de deux
sur ce point d'avoir quelques
inquiétudes que ce soit et en outre
supprimer toute référence à la notion
d'expérience pourrait conduire à
autoriser la titularisation diplômés qui
n'auraient jamais accomplie de stages
professionnels
or ce stage est de deux ans pour le
diplôme supérieur du notariat et
j'ajoute puisque en filigrane ya tout de
même ce point dans le raisonnement que
d'ores et déjà le droit en vigueur
prévoit la validation des acquis de
l'expérience des clercs de notaire de
magistrats judiciaires ou d'avocats se
doit être neuf ans de pratique et
finalement l'amendement proposé apparaît
en retrait par rapport au droit en
vigueur alors par cohérence avec ce que
nous avons voté la semaine dernière je
vous demande de retirer vos amendements
s'ils ont évidemment la vie serait
défavorable
ça c'est pour l'ensemble des amendements
sauf le dernier
de rectifier ces les 722 rectifié alors
l'amendement vise à supprimer de la loi
une condition d'ores et déjà prévues par
décret c'est exact toutefois
l'expérience en scène qui vaut mieux
parfois inscrire dans la loi ce que l'on
veut être certain de trouver dans un
règlement
en outre il serait peu pertinent de
traiter l'une des conditions de
titularisation parce que c'est une
condition titularisation dans le texte
différemment des autres donc ses
observations devant vous rassurer je
vous remercie de bien vouloir envisager
le retrait de votre amendement sinon se
donnera un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre un même avis
du gouvernement donc pardon un mécénat
uci pardon non mais je vous en prie
monsieur karoutchi
c'est très court monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre était juste pour
dire que je suivrai l'avis de la
commission que franchement on peut
considérer que nos collègues peuvent
retirer parce que dans le texte de la
commission
moi je suis pas un fanatique de dire
l'installation aller sur l'expérience et
pas sur le diplôme mais le texte de la
commission est très claire les
conditions d'aptitudes signifie
naturellement un niveau de diplôme
minima atteint pour pouvoir s'installer
la validation de l'expérience est autre
chose mais là je pense que le texte de
la commission est très claire il n'y a
pas de problème sur le niveau de diplôme
pour pouvoir s'installer ça rassure tout
le monde d'ailleurs de de penser que les
notaires ce qui nous allons sont des
gens qui ont un minimum de diplômés
c'est déjà dans le texte donc leur
ajouter ne signifie strictement rien le
gars uci pas d'autres explications de
vote je vais donc m'assurer que ces
amendements sont retirés ou maintenus
monsieur daumier pour le 734 non non
c'était pour le 722 je voulais juste
dire que je suivais la ville monsieur le
rapporteur en le retirant néanmoins il
est bien clair que on n'a rien inventé
puisqu'aujourd'hui on reprend
textuellement ce qui existait déjà c'est
tout ce que je voulais dire c'était
comme pour le secteur 34 précédemment
le 734 et retire également également
donc le 722 et le 722 rectifié par dwan
734 sont retirés les autres amendements
est-ce que leurs auteurs accepte de les
retirer et bien ceux qui ont été
présentés le 228 rétifié qui a été
présentée par monsieur gautier retirer
retirer le 285 rectifié qu'un pièce qui
a été défendu par me dérober dit il est
retiré
il est retiré le 649 éthique et bis des
vents du grenat boulet retirer le 1064
présenté par madame comptiez morin il
est retiré
oui et le 215 rectifié qui est quasiment
identique au premier et retirer aussi
parfait donc tous ses amendements et en
retirer nous en arrivons au 1480 silice
monsieur groggy vous avez la parole
les monsieur le président monsieur
ministre on à monsieur le rapporteur
président de la commission chers
collègues je cet amendement pour but
tout simplement d'instaurer un prend un
plan programmant des installations sur
une meilleure une période triennale est
effectivement je vais pas de détailler
l'ensemble de ce que j'ai écrit dans
cette proposition d'article sur la
partie redonner à 8 mai il absolument
nécessaire effectivement d'avoir une
vision dans le temps et pour l'ensemble
des points
nous proposons qu'il y ait effectivement
une programmation triennale la
concernant l'installation des notaires à
travers les territoires
merci à vis de la commission oui je suis
président le présente amendements dont
vise à instaurer un
prendre un plan triennal de
programmation des installations de
notaire alors ce n'est pas coordonnée
si vous voulez avec le ski était décidé
à l'article 13 bis qui est en tête un
plan de liberté d'installation qui est
encadrée certes et on pourrait
évidemment prévoir que le ministre de la
justice s'engage sur une augmentation
progressive du nombre de notaires en
exercice mais c'est l'objectif de la loi
il n'y a pas lieu tout de même de
préciser cela est alors qu'il faudrait
donc dans le cas où on retiendrait votre
amendement qui encore une fois le
contraire un peu à tout ce que nous
avons fixés dans l'article 13 13 bis
pardon il faudrait prévoir une
coordination entre les deux ce qui
rendrait le mécanisme complexe et non
conforme à l'avis de
la commission spéciale je vois votre
hanche mans peut-être qu'il n'est
peut-être pas opportun que je vous
demande de le retirer
mais ça peut être envisager très
sérieusement sinon ce serait un avis
défavorable
monsieur le ministre un même avis
monsieur gros billets il est maintenu ou
retirés non je le maintiens tout
simplement parce qu'il ya neuf vraiment
nécessité d'avoir une clarté de
projections sur les territoires sur ce
qu'il est possible en terme de
programmation d'installation je crois
que chaque fois qu'on peut s'organiser
et avoir une vision c'est quand même
intéressant notamment pour les jeunes
c'est pour cela que je le maintiens
merci il n'y a pas d'explications de
vote
je le mets donc on voit il s'agit du
1486 avec deux avis défavorables qui est
pour des contre 1,6 s'abstient il le
n'est pas adopté nous passons à deux
amendements en discussion commune le 544
rectifié quater madame derume dit
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues
actuellement la rémunération des
notaires est régi par décret cette
rémunération porte soit sur les
activités traditionnelles des notaires
faisant l'objet du tarif réglementé des
notaires soit sur les prestations de
conseil hors tarifs réglementés
compatible avec la fraude fonction
notariale ses prestations sont rémunérés
par des honoraires fixés d'un commun
accord avec les parties ou à défaut par
le juge chargé de la taxation sont
notamment rémunérées les consultations
donné par les notaires dans ce cas le
client doit être préalablement avertis
par écrit du caractère onéreux de la
prestation de services et du montant
estimé ou du mode de calcul de la
rémunération à prévoir l'article 12 du
projet de loi porte exclusivement sur
l'exercice des prestations soumises au
tarif réglementé des notaires en
revanche rien n'est prévu dans ce projet
sur les honoraires de conseil or le
conseil est bien un élément inhérent à
la fonction de notaire
il est donc étonnant que les
dispositions régissant les honoraires
versés au titre de prestations de
conseil ne soit pas abordée dans un
souci de cohérence notre amendement
propose de faire remonter au niveau de
la loi les dispositions concernant les
prestations de conseil au même titre que
celles couvertes par le tarif qui
jusqu'à présent était tout régi par le
décret du 8 mars 1978
merci le 691 n'est pas défendu avis de
la commission sur un porteur je leur
prends parce que il est exactement le
même
il est fixé donc comment il est
identique les deux amendements sont
identiques d'accord et c'est mon
commentaire sera donc commun ces deux
amendements identiques
l'amendement ces amendements visent à
préciser qu'en dehors des actes tarifés
les prestations des notaires sont
pendants honoraires libres et que la
fixation de ses honoraires répond aux
mêmes exigences que celle des avocats
services rendus difficultés de la sphère
frais exposés par le notaire diligence
de celui-ci et conventions d'honoraires
préalable la précision selon laquelle en
dehors des tarifs l'honorer libye n'est
sans doute pas nécessaire toutefois elle
peut rassurer et ont cadré la fixation
des honoraires en prenant pour modèle
les avocats que tu as fait pertinents
l'amendement appelle donc un avis
favorable se réserve de lui apporter
plusieurs rectification dessinée
notamment reprendre les principaux
éléments du régime de fixation des
honoraires d'avocat j'ai transmis
facile précisions ont été données à la
commission spéciale transmise à la
séance et sous réserve de celle ci je
donne un avis favorable à ces
amendements très bien monsieur le
ministre
alors est ce que c'est c'est des
rectifications demandé par la commission
peuvent être distribués c'est bon
monsieur le ministre est présent oui je
vois bien l'objet de l'amendement phase
a été rappelé par le rapporteur mais à
partir du moment où il s'agirait des
prestations qui ne sont pas réglementées
par le décret 60,18 je vois pas pourquoi
on veut justement le préciser dans la
loi on ne parle là que des tarifs
réglementés donc honnêtement je j'ai
peur que soit inutilement verbeux à
vouloir préciser ce qui existe déjà
donc moi j'aurai un avis de retrait
parce que je pense que defacto vous êtes
satisfait par le dispositif puisque on
ne touche par ailleurs que les activités
qui font l'objet d'un tarif réglementé
or les prestations de conseil on a eu le
débat samedi ne font pas l'objet d'un
tarif réglementé pour aucune de ces
professions donc moi j'aurais plutôt une
demande de retrait ce que je pense que
ça ne sert à rien et que ça pourrait au
contraire créer une forme de début de on
introduit des tarifs flic dans la loi
donc c'est le début d'une forme de
réglementation par cette reconnaissance
donc moi je vous conseillerais plutôt le
retrait collectif
s'il n'y a pas de retrait ces avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre
très bien alors vous en distribuant
souvent les deux amendements rectifier
monsieur le rapporteur est ce que vous
pourriez en quelques mots indiqué les
modifications que vous y avez apporté
pour faciliter la lecture par nos
collègues indiqué en quoi elle consiste
la rectification supprime la référence à
l'exemple de la consultation qui
introduit une difficulté puisqu'elle
pourrait être interprété comme ouvrant
aux notaires la possibilité de faire
payer leurs clients par le biais de nos
horaires la consultation juridique qui
leur fournirait dans le cadre de la
rédaction d'un acte pour lequel ils sont
déjà soumis à un tarif
or les sols consultation détaché de tout
acte tarifs et sont susceptibles de
donner lieu à la perception d'honoraires
voilà la raison de précision qui avaient
été apportées à cet article vous avez
désormais sous les yeux alors
explications de vote monsieur karoutchi
président du mini si je voulais donner
dans le jeu médiatique
je dirais mais à quoi ça sert que du
groupe des carcasses nous avons adopté
samedi un de mes amendements l'un des
rares que monsieur le ministre a bien
voulu adopter dans sa bonté d'âme disant
clairement que en dehors de tout ce qui
était arrivé réglementé il y avait
liberté tarifaire sur l'ensemble des
opérations des notaires et c'est à dire
qu'en réalité les amendements qui
arrivent aujourd'hui sont satisfaits par
l'amendement adopté samedi dernier et je
serais tenté de dire à leurs auteurs que
je préfère en rester pardon à mon
amendement de samedi dernier qui
laissait une liberté pleine et entière
plutôt qu aux amendements actuel qui
disent d'une part qu'il ya liberté
tarifaire en dehors des tarifs
réglementés pour les opérations
classiques mais qui en même temps fixe
un cadre ce qui va à linverse de
probablement la volonté des auteurs
alors soit on en reste à dire c'est
extrêmement simple
dès que vous sortez des tarifs
réglementés
ils sont sur des secteurs où il n'ya pas
de concurrence par définition c'est
réglementé c'est encadré par la loi et
pour le reste puisque ça ne l'est pas
dans un secteur qui est qui ne ce qui
est ouvert en réalité à la concurrence
laissons le la concurrence agir je ne
vois pas très bien
l'objectif des auteurs parce que si
c'est pour les encadrer ce qu'on a
libéré samedi je vois pas où on va là et
moi je serais tenté de dire à monsieur
le ministre pour une fois libéral que
franchement je préfère son avis qui
consiste à dire
restons-en à la libération hors tarifs
réglementés et ne rien cadres ont pas
par des normes nouvelles c'est pas la
loi de dire ce que doivent être les
tarifs libres dans un secteur
concurrentiel où l on s'en sortira
jamais merci monsieur les rotules
monsieur pouvoir pour explication de
vote
oui monsieur le président à
l'intervention de roger karoutchi va me
permettre des plus courts parce que
effectivement il y à des tarifs
réglementés sur des chants bien précis
et je ne vois pas l'intérêt d'aller
ajouter le fait qu'il doit y avoir des
conventions en fin de de légiférer à
outrance sur des choses qui relèvent du
libre exercice des activités des
professions libérales du commerce et
cetera
donc je pense que le pour le coup nous
sommes avec des amendements qui n'ont
pas de réelle utilité au fond si ce
n'est d'ajouter de l'incertitude dans le
fonctionnement et dans la loi bien
plus d'explications de vote alors 2e à
porter le président compte tenu des
explications qui ont été fournis aussi
bien par monsieur le ménisque par notre
collègue roger karoutchi
il faut dire également que l'amendement
nous disputions au nous discutons
aujourd'hui avait été voilà il a été
déposée avant de ce qui a été fait la
semaine dernière mais je pense
effectivement que sur ce point on peut
trouver un large consensus ici même de
revenir retire son amendement la
commission spéciale retirera le sien ce
qui fait qu'en tout début d'après midi
nous serons dans une voie de consensus
général dont on ne peut espérer qu'ils
continueraient à être madame desrosiers
acceptez-vous de retirer votre
amendement à la demande de la commission
il est retiré donc les deux amendements
sont retirés nous avons épuisé les
amendements sur l'article 14 et je vais
donc la fiq le 14 ou vois pas
d'explication de de vote donc et pour
l'article 14 des contrats dits
s'abstient l'article 14 est adoptée nous
passons à l'article 15 avec un
amendement 342 présentée par monsieur
joyandet
vous avez la parole oui monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je vais me servir de cet
amendement pour faire une remarque qu'on
a sans doute fait peut-être plusieurs
dizaines de fois monsieur le ministre
pour vous dire que votre loi comme
beaucoup d'autres lois qui nous sont
proposés depuis un certain temps je
pense à la loue un autre notamment
elle fait un peu pour les c'est à dire
pour les parisii pour les parisiens mais
comme je ne veux pas caricaturer je veux
dire que je vais dire pour les je vais
dire pour les zones urbaines
parce que c'est ce que je ressens en
territoire rural notamment ce qui
concerne la déréglementation des
professions réglementées chez-nous
j'allais dire dans les petits
départements ruraux
on peut pas comparer j'élargis mais je
ne prendrai pas la parole souvent
monsieur le président je me permet
d'élargir au delà de cet amendement dans
les zones comme les nôtres quand
quand on n'a pas grand chose en terme
d'aménagement du territoire et qu'on a
ces professions réglementées
le fait de tout des réglementés c'est
encore un petit peu moins de péréquation
est un tout et encore moins
d'aménagement du territoire
un exemple si les avocats
évidemment le sens plus relié à leur tgi
mais leur cour d'appel si les huissiers
sont pu relire désigna leur cour d'appel
chez nous on interprète ça comme à terme
un risque de voir disparaître tout
simplement un moment donné un os
tribunaux de grande à ceux de grande
instance
on n'a pas la même densité on n'a pas la
même densité de nos professions
réglementées on n'a pas la même densité
nos professions juridiques et ce qui se
fait dans les grandes zones urbaines n'a
rien à voir avec ce qui se fait chez
nous la crainte qui est ressentie aussi
bien par les élus que par les
professionnels en question c'est
justement de voir cette ouverture
générale qui fera que des avocats
d'ailleurs des huissiers de justice
d'ailleurs viendront chez nous prendre
le peu d'affaires qui reste alors quand
vous pensez que dans les territoires
comme les nôtres on a un pouvoir d'achat
par tête d'habitant qui est quand même
très bas les professions qui montent
encore un petit peu la moyenne générale
du professeur du pouvoir d'achat ce sont
ces professions là donc j'ai tendance à
dire dans les départements en dessous
d'une certaine densité
il faudrait sans doute fait un peu plus
prudent pour tous déréglementé que dans
les zones urbaines
c'est comme ça d'ailleurs et qu'on a vu
dans la loi un autre que au début on
nous assurons nous a proposé la
suppression des départements qui posait
sans doute pas de problème dans les
grandes zones urbaines dans nos
départements ruraux sa peau s'est plaint
de problèmes finalement il ya eu un
recul du gouvernement parce qu'il ya une
une très forte contestation de
l'ensemble des élus là ya moins de
contestation parce que dans les
professions réglementées
entre ceux qui finalement sont pas
tellement contre parce qu'ils sont dans
les grandes zones
et puis le peu de gens qui se mobilisent
au fond il ya assez peu de monde pour
parler au nom de ces professionnels dans
les départements ruraux
je pense qu'il ya un vrai danger de voir
dans des départements où on a déjà un
seuil d'équipements très faible très
faible y compris en termes de voies de
communication
là on a un système qui fonctionne en
national si on a l'impression qu'on va
encore
encore casser quelque chose qui
fonctionne encore à peu près bien après
les difficultés pour le commerce
indépendant l'artisanat les pmi pme dans
ces territoires là on a l'impression que
le peu qui reste encore debout
eh bien on va finalement le mettre par
terre je vous fais je vous fais part
juste de ce sentiment
c'est le sens de cette de cet amendement
c'est pas un amendement pour dire on
supprime tout à fait rien mais mon
message il est celui là c'est pour ça
que j'avais déposé cet amendement
sachant que je pourrai pas tout c'est
défendre et je profite de celui là pour
d'une façon générale aborder cette
véritable inquiétude pour nos
territoires
et puis je verrai ce que je fais de cet
amendement quand j'aurais entendu la
commission et vous même monsieur minutes
merci monsieur le rapporteur
oui ce président ninis mon cher collègue
jus parfaitement compris votre votre
position qui n'est pas loin de celle que
nous avons implicitement soutenu pas
totalement d'ailleurs en matière de
postulation mais votre amendement on ne
supprimerait pas seulement l'extension
du ressort de compétence des huitièmes
aussi la limite tâche donc déjà
uniquement à raison de ce point parce
que nous venons de dissiper différemment
juge émettra un avis défavorable mais je
vais pas fuir le le débat sur
l'extension du record de durfort de
compétences le ressort de compétence des
officiers a beaucoup évolué en peu de
temps
il est passé du tribunal d'instance otg
puis il ya peu de temps et même pas un
an au département et donc le cet article
prévoit de l'étendre à tout le
territoire pour la plupart des
prestations à l'exception des
significations qui serait limitée aux
ressort de la cour d'appel
je dois vous dire que les huissiers de
justice que j'ai interrogées sont parce
que c'était évidemment un point
important sont d'accord avec cette
extension il souhaite uniquement et nous
l'avons incorporé dans le texte il va
venir en amont en tout cas leur qui se
trouvera d'ailleurs satisfait à la
condition qu'ils disposent d'un temps
suffisant pour s'y préparer de la
commission spéciale a d'ailleurs prévu
en différant l'entrée en vigueur au
au 1er janvier 2017 sané l'énergie pas
beaucoup le comment dirais-je la palette
de leurs compétences sur un territoire
plus vaste parce que pour la plupart de
leurs prestations en particulier toutes
celles qui sont hors monopole
les huissiers dispose déjà d'un ressort
de compétences plus larges que le
département
c'est la raison pour laquelle le 6 e
pour les questions principe que vous
avez évoqué vous ne retirez pas votre
amendement
je les mettrais un avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre président je vais
d'ailleurs en même temps dire deux mots
de l'amendement gouvernemental visant le
721 pour les débutants moi j'entends
votre crainte et je crois que toutes les
discussions qu'on a pu avoir ces jours
derniers celle qu'on aura montre que l
ai prise en compte la réforme qui
portait sur les professions réglementées
ne va pas dans ce sens pourquoi parce
que d'abord où ne déséquilibre pas les
zones qui sont pourvus de manière
satisfaisante en professionnel on l'a
évoqué avec cette cartographie qui est
mise en place et que la haute assemblée
a voté c'est que on voit bien que la
liberté relative d'installation se fera
dans les zones où il ya un manque de
professionnels installés et donc les
zones plus rurales auront la chance de
voir de nouveaux professionnels qui
pourront venir s'installer si elle était
carencée aujourd'hui j'ajoute à cela
qu'on a même créé un fonds de
péréquation qui n'existait pas
jusqu'alors dans ces professions qui a
été un apport du texte des dé celui qui
vous a été transmis
ça n'a pas été modifié au sénat mais
nous avions pris en compte les intérêts
des territoires en faisant exister une
péréquation qui n'existait pas jusqu'à
lors contrairement à beaucoup de
discours qui a vécu est reporté
donc je crois que ce texte sera mieux
disant pour les territoires les plus
ruraux et dans les territoires où il ya
suffisamment une professionnelle
il y aura pas de liberté d'installation
c'est le statu quo qui sera préservée
alors dans dans le l'article présent que
que vous proposez de supprimer il ya en
effet d'une part l'extension à la cour
d'appel et là j'ai noté
et c'est vrai que les échanges qu'on
avec la profession aussi qu'il y avait
un petit décalage au 1er janvier 2010
est de l'entrée en vigueur
et moi j'ai souscrit volontiers donc je
ne propose pas dans l'amendement
gouvernemental de revenir sur le délai
de mise en vigueur parce que comme l'a
dit le rapporteur au 1er janvier 2015 on
a étendu aux départements
donc il faut donner de la visibilité du
temps et donc qui est cette montée en
charge progressive nous nous convient
donc ça c'est un premier point
le deuxième point c'est la limite de 70
ans et là je proposerai et c'est l'objet
de l'amendement 721 comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure en cohérence de se donner
un délai de six mois
on a ce désaccord sur ce point mais qui
n'est pas substantielle mais ce qui me
permet ce faisant de dire pourquoi nous
avons déposé l'amendement 721 ensuite
mais je pense vraiment que ce serait
dommage de supprimer cet article qui
permet aussi à certains offices de duy
cible d'aller chercher la matière comme
ils le disent sur d'autres territoires
parce qu'il y a déjà eu en effet en
raison du numerus clausus de la
profession est bien une raréfient
raréfication sur le territoire de
certains de ses offices donc on va
permettre d'une part à des jeunes de
s'installer mais d'étendre aussi leur
ressort et vous savez ça ne sera pas
forcément un avantage pour le fait
métropolitain et donc les traits ronds
les territoires ruraux verront des
opportunités aussi une nouvelle s'offrir
à travers l'ensemble de la réforme c'est
ce qu'on a discuté samedi
donc moi je vous inviterai en retrait
sinon j'aurai un avis défavorable et je
considère monsieur le président que le
721 et ce faisant défendu merci monsieur
joyandet
le président est le ministre le
président de la commission je vais
retirer cet amendement
évidemment dans mon explication dans ma
présentation tout à l'heure je vous ai
dit je saisisse elle l'occasion de cet
amendement pour élargir mon propos je
maintiens ce que je dis 1 concernant ma
crainte près secteur e vo pas
spécifiquement pour les lycées parce que
j'ai compris qu'ils étaient finalement
assez d'accord donc si on nous dit
qu'ils sont d'accord on va pas faire le
bonheur malgré évidemment mais pour le
reste des profs et des autres
professions avocats et notaires
moi j'entends encore aujourd'hui
beaucoup de d'inquiétude dans nos
territoires je veux m'en faire l'écho
ici hausse à la représentation nationale
parce que j'ai pas l'impression que sur
le terrain les choses soient ressentis
avec autant de positivisme que celui qui
est le vôtre monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur joyandet l'amendement est
donc retiré
et nous passons à deux amendements
discussion commune le 721 a été défendue
par le gouvernement
le 224 rectifié monsieur wauquiez
sa collègue il s'agit simplement
d'appliquer donc aux huissiers de
justice la proposition qu'ont proposé
pour les notaires le succès qu'on va lui
dire de se supprimer la limitation de
l'âge qui est monsieur le rapporteur ce
président par cohérence si j'ose dire il
est évident que le cese 121 je peux
donner qu'un avis défavorable puisque
s'il était d'ailleurs admis il
introduirait une incohérence totale dans
le texte de votre rayon cet après midi
est donc peut-être d'ailleurs monsieur
le ministre vous pu puisque ça ne nous
empêchera pas de revenir dessus l
assemblée nationale de le retirer
et puis le second bien évidemment c'est
également là même la même remarque
contenu ce que nous avons voté tout à
leur donner qu'un avis défavorable peut
pas faire aux huissiers de justice en
l'espèce une qui sont officier public ou
ministériel on peut pas leur faire il
n'a un statut différent que celui qu'on
a voté il ya quelques minutes pour les
notaires à propos de l'âge dans cali
défavorable également je vais mettre
voileux 721 pas d'explications de vote
monsieur longuet et le bouveret
merci monsieur le président michel lis
mes chers collègues moi je défendrai
l'amendement qui a été excellemment
présenté au nom de monsieur mesa par
notre collègue briquet parce que
vraiment les blocages d'âge c'est
absurde et ailleurs nous en sommes le
témoignage vivant dans cette assemblée
et nous sommes dans une autre nous
sommes dans des professions qui sont
fondamentalement libéral certes investis
pour partie de mission de service public
mais il appartient
nous sommes en visant libéral aux
clients d'évaluer la validité
si la personne est cacochyme inapte et
bernard but clients
et puis la sphère s'éteindra d'elle-même
pourquoi diable surtout que 70 ans
réfléchit c'est monsieur le ministre ça
vient très vite ça vient très très vite
beaucoup plus vite qu'on ne le croit et
il arrive même il arrive même qu'à cet
âge avancé on puisse exercer des
responsabilités sans parler de
clemenceau il y attendent exemple que je
ne vois pas pourquoi la loi viendrait au
secours de cette guillotine devrait
répondre à mon ami joyandet
mon collègue et ami alain joyandet je
regrette qu'il ait retiré son amendement
je leur ai défendu non pas pour défaire
le projet de la commission qui était
pertinent mais parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre que l'ouverture territoriale
va je le pense profondément vider les
départements des meilleurs libéraux je
dis bien des meilleurs c'est à dire ceux
qui iront chercher les lieux où se
trouve la meilleure clientèle car le
fond de la profession libérale et les
noté ali visés sont des professions
libérales
c'est d'aller chercher le client là où
il est solvable exigeant capable de vous
faire progresser parce que ces attentes
sont également des attentes importantes
et ce que je crains dans dans cette
ouverture c'est pas tellement que les
grandes villes aille vers le monde rural
mais c'est que les meilleurs du monde
rural
on profite pour s'installer en grande
ville où ils trouveront des meilleures
clientes c'est en fait la raréfaction
des professions libérales y compris les
médecins d'ailleurs s'explique par
l'éloignement des centres de décisions
des centres de formation auxquels sont
naturellement lié les professions
libérales
il faut accepter l'idée de d'examiner
l'évolution des textes que nous votons à
la lumière de mouvements de population
de mouvements de prestataires de
services libéraux qui comme l'on fait
avant que
les banques privées les banques
coopératives les banques mutualistes les
caisses des femmes les directions
administratives de l'état se regroupent
non pas vers les métropoles
départementale si on peut parler de
métropole pour la plupart de nos
préfectures
né vers les métropoles régionales et
aboutissants inéluctablement à faire en
sorte que des territoires n'est plus les
prestataires auxquels ils peuvent
accéder pour pouvoir se développer mais
je n'ai pas la nôtre quid ans de penser
ou la naïveté de penser que par la loi
on peut empêcher les évolutions de fond
qui sont des évolutions de la société
la tertiarisation c'est le monde urbain
le monde urbain
c'est en effet le contraire des mondes
le râble merci monsieur pouvoir et merci
il se présente je crois que c'est je
suis pas toujours loin s'en faut en
désaccord avec gérard longuet mais je
pense que c'est justement parce que nous
sommes avec des professions réglementées
et donc qu'ils ferment l'accès aux plus
jeunes qu'il faut que nous permettions
un renouvellement en assurant une
capacité d'installation pour les plus
jeunes si on veut que le le tissu
générationnel se renouvellent
progressivement pour ce qui me concerne
le ressort des cours d'appel comme
périmètres ne paraître périmètre
raisonnable j'observe que la profession
des huissiers de justice dans le cadre
d'un dialogue qui a été construit de
manière constructif avec le gouvernement
a donné son accord sur ces dispositions
et je trais donc l'amendement du
gouvernement
alors je sais pas si ça pose un problème
de cohérence par rapport à ce qu'il ya
eu tout à l'heure pour pour les notaires
sur le sujet des six mois pour ce qui me
concerne j'ai voté également
l'amendement sur les dispositions des
six mois et je pense que c'est une
mesure de bon sens et en tout état cause
qui ne m'entraîne pas de bouleversements
et qui permet d'avoir une
sion judicieuse de cette affaire et
monsieur le rapporteur rapporté apporter
une précision puis rassurer mon collègue
lentilles sur sur cette question alors
premièrement effectivement mais ça
allait ambitions viendra pas professions
libérales certes mais officiers publics
et ministériels ou ministériel ce qui
signifie que l'organisation de la
profession elle-même est à la main de
ceux qui créent elles et les monopoles
ou les offices à c'est la question qui
ne posera pas de problème entre nous sur
la seconde sur l'âge il n'y a aucune
opposition des professions sur cette
mesure et je n'ai pas fait une étude
très poussée de la pyramide des âges
chez les notaires mais tout ce que je
sais c'est qu'il y a après ce qu'ils ont
à l'heure actuelle 70 ans qui sont en
passe de la voir une certaine pépinière
importante de notre père salarié de
notaire assistant qui peuvent le devenir
et éventuellement de claire habilité
dans les conditions jules indiqué tout à
l'heure donc je ne suis pas inquiet sur
ce point et surtout comme l'indiqué
notre dernier collègues qui a pris la
parole aussi bien les huissiers que les
notaires ont clairement indiqué qu'ils
n'arrêtent pas de problème sur ce point
et il en était d'accord
donc si vous voulez je pense qu' il n'y
a pas lieu d'aller plus loin que ne le
veulent
les professions sur ce point dès lors
qu' il ya un accord on l'homologue et
point la ligne 6 donc je vais mettre
voir s'il n'ya plus d'explications de
vote et je n'en vois pas l'amendement
1621 du gouvernement avec un avis
défavorable de la commission qui est
pour et qui est contre du s'abstient il
n'est pas adoptée et jeu mais se voit de
224 rectifié qui et pour qui contraint
qui s'abstient n'est pas adoptée à
l'article 15
il nous reste à examiner le 274 rectifié
monsieur wauquiez vise à différer la
mise à jour de l'évolution de la
compétence territoriale des usa justice
au premier jour du 18ème mois après
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi et ce afin
de garantir les meilleures conditions
aux cervidés vicky sia bhl est donnée à
l'accès à la justice sur le territoire
cela permettra fière d'en tenir compte
du délai de la boration du règlement
d'application de ces traits de ses
réserves dans passerait de six mois la
démo sur le rapporteur cet amendement
part est nécessairement satisfait
puisque le texte de la commission après
une entrée en vigueur au 1er janvier
et cette date devant intervenir
vraisemblablement 18 mois donc après la
promulgation de la présente loi en
juillet donc techniquement
pratiquement il est satisfait le demande
de bien vouloir retirer ce mini même
avis monsieur wauquiez il est maintenu
et les retirer donc je me revois
l'article 15 pas d'explications de vote
qui est pour l'article 15 qui est
contraint qui s'abstient
la fiq le 15 est adoptée à l'article 16
un amendement 1622 du gouvernement il
est défendu
monsieur le rapporteur des favoris même
logique que pour les autres
mais je je profite toutefois de cet
amendement pour monsieur le ministre
vous interroger sur le mécanisme de
liberté totale d'installation que
voudriez rétablir dans les zones
carences et qui font l'objet d'un appel
à manifestation d'intérêt la collection
spéciale a supprimé cette disposition
parce qu'elle pourrait aboutir à une
situation anarchique dans laquelle
plusieurs commissaires priseurs
judiciaires ouvrir simultanément des
bureaux secondaires dans certains ne
seraient que de simples façade destinée
à empêcher ou en tout cas dit cela dès
l'installation de nouveaux
professionnels
je pense qu'il est paradoxal dans une
zone carences et d'autoriser sans aucune
régulation
l'installation de bureaux secondaires
alors qu'on ouvre un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt pour que
s'installe plutôt un nouvel office
m'enfin dans le même ordre d'idée tout à
l'heure tu es un avis défavorable
merci monsieur bébé puisse répondre à ce
point c'est la discussion qu'on a eue
samedi dans les zones carences et il ya
un appel à projets on veut pas se
limiter à un examen on l'a déjà dit moi
un concours et donc on renvoie au niveau
réglementaire l'organisation de cet
appel à projet qui prend en compte les
différents critères qu'on a pu discuter
samedi c'est exactement la même logique
que celle que j'ai pu évoquer samedi
après-midi lors de notre discussion et
pas d'explications de vote je vais donc
aux voileux 1622 avec un avis
défavorable de la commission qui est
pour et qui est contre un qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adoptée nous en arrivons au
1065 madame cohen oui merci monsieur le
président notre amendement vise à
rappeler l'exigence d'un diplôme pour
exercer la profession de commissaire
priseur judiciaire
d'ailleurs c'est certainement un objet
qui s'apparente beaucoup à un moment que
nous avons fait tout à l'heure
concernant les notaires l'alinéa 4 ne
prévoit ici aussi qu'une condition
d'aptitude ou d'expérience mais ne
mentionne pas la nécessité d'une
qualification professionnelle adaptée
donc c'est ce qui nous paraît être
nécessaire de réaffirmer tout à l'heure
monsieur le rapporteur nous a expliqué
que pour ce qui concernait les notaires
c'était déjà dans la loi et que donc ce
n'était pas nécessaire de dire venir
donc la remet aimerait avoir des
explications pour savoir si
effectivement notre amendement
finalement est inutile parce que c'est
déjà inclus dans la loi si tel n'était
pas le cas nous sommes au niveau du
groupe c r c'est toujours fervent
partisan de demander de reconnaître
l'exigence de diplômes qui permettent
effectivement la qualification et
l'égalité entre les professions donc
voilà il nous semble que compétences
aptitudes ça n'est pas suffisant et que
donc il ya ce besoin de d'ajouter la
reconnaissance de diplômes et c'est le
sens de notre amendement chanteur oui
chers collègues
l'amendement renvoi décret précis celui
du 19 juin 1973 la fixation de la
condition de l'aptitude professionnelle
d'un point de vue logistique le renvoi
est irrégulier la loi procédant à un
renvoi général un type d'actes
réglementaires et non pas un texte
précis qui peut être librement rapporté
modifiées ou supprimées par le
gouvernement mais sur le fond il n'y a
pas de difficultés sur ce point il y en
a pas plus que pour les notaires comme
je l'expliqué tout à l'heure
l'amendement de me paraît donc pas utile
mais j'ajoute que le gouvernement sera
certainement vous rassurer sur le
maintien d'une haute qualification pour
l'exercice de la profession de
commissaire priseur judiciaire
donc je suggérais un retrait au bénéfice
des explications du gouvernement
oui j'aurais les mêmes explications pour
pour demander le retrait puisque en
effet c'est ce qu'ont les discussions
qu'on a qu'on appuie tout à l'heure je
ici par ailleurs pouvoir vous dire que
l'exercice de ses missions très
spécialisés en effet elle suppose
aujourd'hui un double cursus en droit et
en histoire de l'art une très bonne
connaissance de la valeur du mobilier du
matériel du stock des entreprises pour
intervenir utilement dans les procédures
collectives et on le gouvernement
n'entend pas revenir sur ces conditions
je crois que c'est ce que vous vouliez
que celui-ci clarifiée bon donc c'est ce
faisant
maintenant clarifiée et elles figureront
bien dans le décret en conseil d'état
merci monsieur et madame cohen
simplement une petite demande de
précision c'est à dire que pour ces
professions là aussi c'est à dire au
niveau des commissaires priseurs
il y a effectivement j'ai bien entendu
au niveau des formations etc
mais c'est c'est validé par un diplôme
toujours c'est à dire c'est pas il ya
une une certification et c'est toujours
voilà c'est juste la précision que
j'aimerais voir pour retirer mon monde
d'amendements oui voilà pour l'examen du
projet de loi macro et les dispositions
concernant la liberté d'installation des
notaires on reviendra sur les
professions réglementées dans 24heures
sénat le journal s'est tout de suite